[Music]
in the music industry winning a grammy
is the ultimate accolade
the national academy of recording arts
and sciences has been awarding grammys
for recordings since 1958.
every year the winners are honored with
a golden gramophone trophy
[Music]
the grammys are to the music industry
what the oscars
are to movies the coveted trophy is made
of gold-plated gramium
but don't look for that metal on the
periodic table
it's a proprietary zinc alloy specially
formulated and trademarked by the
artisan who makes the grammys
to make the base of the trophy they heat
the gramium to 644 degrees
and pour it into a bronze mold
they immediately pour out the excess
molten metal
what remains quickly solidifies in a
thin layer against the walls of the
cavity
creating a hollow cast
they also cast the gramophone's cabinet
and tone arm in gramium
they remove mold seams excess metal and
smooth out the surface of each cast
component with a belt sander
[Music]
then they file by hand the areas the
belt can't reach
[Music]
finally they polish the metal with an
abrasive compound on a buffing wheel
they make sure there are no surface
imperfections
now they work on the gramophone's iconic
horn
using a metal shear they cut a disc of
malleable bronze
they mount the disc on a lathe
as the lathe spins they use a series of
tools to transform the flat disc
into a horn
[Music]
then they spin the horn on a different
lathe pressing an abrasive cloth against
the surface
to remove any tool marks before they
connect the tone arm to the cabinet
they brush on some flux a chemical that
makes the stationary solder
flow into the tiny gap between
components
now they bolt the tone arm to the
cabinet then
solder
[Music]
they submerge this part of the trophy in
a degreasing solution for a few minutes
then in water
gold doesn't adhere to zinc so they
plate it with copper
they run a positive electric charge
through the trophy
and a negative charge through a piece of
copper also suspended in the plating
tank
this process dissolves the copper then
draws the particles through the water
and onto the trophy
they repeat the electroplating process
in a different tank
this time with nickel nickel creates a
sufficiently hard base to support the
gold plating
it also makes gold appear brighter
after another rinse it's back into a
tank for the final plating
with 24 karat gold
[Music]
to prepare the trophy's base for
painting they smooth the surface with a
belt sander
then fine sand by hand
they spray on an epoxy primer let it dry
for a day
then wet sand it with fine sandpaper
they repeat these steps with the black
primer
then paint the base with high gloss chip
resistant black paint
once it dries they can finish assembling
the trophy
they bolt the polished gold-plated
cabinet and tone arm to the painted base
then they take the horn which has been
gold plated and polished
and screw it into the tone arm
[Music]
after 15 hours of craftsmanship this
grammy is ready to be awarded
but this trophy won't be handed out
during the award show
the grammys handed out on stage are
actually props that are used year after
year
the winners receive a personalized
trophy a few weeks after the show
the base has a brass plate engraved with
their name
and musical category
you